nelson getting ready to make his second
start and appearance of this 20-21
season he's coming back from the forearm
tightness and a trip on the 10-day
injured list he worked for the only time
this regular season april 21st against
milwaukee he threw two shutout innings
he allowed only a hit and a walk the
pirates making a little bit of noise
here and the slumping third baseman eric
gonzalez at the plate and that's a
ground ball to third base should be the
inning man he's got it goes the short
way and they will force out moran at
second base to the inning so no harm no
foul with the back to back two out
singles here we go with mitch keller
start number six
pennsylvania lottery numbers
let's see if mitch
can improve those across the board and i
think that starts as we mentioned
getting ahead of hitters pounding the
strike zone
command of that fastball
two outs pro far at first we'll see if
he
attempts to go
during this sequence to eric hosmer fly
ball out to left
tom
has the catch a nice easy inning and so
the walk left stranded we're through one
yeah the pirates and padres are
scoreless pitch 25 of the night coming
up for to nelson lumet with one out one
on hot shot eats up manny gets up and
over him into foul ground kim will go
get it now the throw to third is gonna
be close and out there third a second
safe there
nice play by hassan kim going to get
that ball
and they're able to throw out tom at
third base
jumped up off of machado and into short
left kim goes and gets it and then
throws out the base runner third two
down well you can see why hassan kim won
a gold glove in the kbo this kid is all
over the place
he's trying to work his way around a
lead off double by adam frazier it
starts syncs here in the third inning
for the pirates and olds grounded out to
short in the first inning goal for one
tonight line shot into center field and
that will bring home the run no shutout
tonight friars
into second base goes brian reynolds
double one nothing pittsburgh and
reynolds continues to hit lefties that
was a rocket he hit off a lefty there
that
it's not just the batting average just
uh
how hard he's hitting the ball off those
guys that's his tenth double now that
leads
the tide for the national league league
it's keller a five-year-old from cedar
rapids iowa this is manny machado
fastball strike three call he strikes
him out again this time looking i used
to be a little too patient
fourth strikeout for keller one out in
the fourth seven in a row now retired by
mitch keller who has really kind of
settled into this outing curveball
swinging a miss an elevated curveball to
meyers way out in front
and he hit against so keller they have
sent down eight straight padres he has
struck down five the fifth inning is
coming up the pirates lead in san diego
one to nothing sliced and there's the
first major league hit for mitch keller
a base hit to right
and he leads off the fifth inning with a
solid single
he's got a big smile on his face all
right yeah he's pretty stoic most of the
time but
in fact i don't ever see him smile about
pitching but he's smiling about getting
that hit yeah that's great
in his third major league season
it's his first hit remember last year
pitchers didn't bat
two up two down as keller seems to be
gaining more and more confidence i love
what's uh happening for him here tonight
again it
looks confident it's aggressive the fly
ball
softly hit out toward left center
reynolds calling for it
and he makes a catch in the inning end
so mitch keller
66 pitches
through five innings remember he needed
47 to get through the first sitting in
his last start gonzales at first with
one out and the catcher jacob stallings
coming up runner goes from first and a
swing and a miss throw down to second
base is high and a good job by
cronenworth going up and preventing that
one from going into center field stolen
base for eric gonzalez his first of the
season so an insurance run in scoring
position for the pirates and there goes
your ground ball double play opportunity
runner goes again and a ground ball
poked over to the right side chronoworth
got it throw to first lazy hosmer has to
throw home and everybody is safe how
about gonzales
and a safe call at first base
how about that that is some great
baseball right there stallings is going
to be credited with the fielder's choice
rbi with a runner at second base with
the runner at second base
gonzalez with the good jump the ball was
slowly hit
he doesn't hesitate
around third
maybe he does hesitate a little bit but
he saw how slow the play was developing
figured hey i'll take a risk one out
grisham now in scoring position this
time the padres are better runner
reached second
line to center field reynolds coming in
to make the catch oh he dropped it
on the transfer
or on the fly
i don't think he caught it is what
they're saying on the transfer he
dropped it it came out
and we'll see if the padre is going to
challenge this the call on the field is
out
but it sure looked like it was moving
around and that glove out there and
center field popped out
i don't see it the potter is going to
challenge this says
here's the play again you know what i'm
i'm just trying to equate this to a turn
at second base on a double i got catch
yeah and dropped on the transfer i i
would rule that account i think they got
it right yeah yes that's the night for
keller he ends up throwing 83 pitches he
departs responsible for grisham at third
machado at first enter sam howard right
through the shortstop kevin newman so
the hook closed
mitch keller five two thirds scoreless
one out and myers at second base tying
run at the plate nola grounds went back
up the middle and into center field here
comes myers around with the first run of
the night for the padres
and for the second straight night austin
nola drives in a 7th inning run it's a
2-1 game austin nola with another big
hit got his first one yesterday
he gets his second one today austin nola
is at second base he represents a tying
run friar faithful happy to see fernando
a swing
on the splitter out towards second base
frazier will call off moran and that
ends the inning a run on two hits
well on his richard rodriguez richard
rodriguez the 31 year old
four seamer and a slider pretty much two
pitches
[Applause]
heavy on the four seamer it tries to
locate that
and when you talk about velocity he's
not really that overpowering
93-ish
enters his 11th game he's got four saves
and four opportunities one more out to
get to snap a five-game losing streak
swinging a fly ball out to left deep and
caught at the wall by tom
and nola give it a ride trying to tie it
and that's how this ball game ends